2017.
THE YEAR.
CHECK THIS.
COME ON, LET'S GO.
THE WORLD TODAY.
SO MUCH WAR.
SO MUCH INJUSTICE.
I HATE THE BAD MEN.
HIP HOP.
JAY Z.
YEAH.
COMO.
THE WORLD IS SHORT.
MARTIN LUTHER KING DID THE
MARCH.
YOU HAVE MY RESPECT.
♪ SO MUCH PAIN IN THE USA
SO MUCH PAIN IN THE WORLD
TODAY I SAID WHY I SAID WHY
I SAID WHY ♪
♪ WHY ARE WE FIGHTING FOR ♪
>> YEAH, I HOPE THE PEOPLE KNOW
THAT I CARE.
THAT I'LL ALWAYS WANT THE PEACE.
OBAMA, TRUMP, BUSH.
>> THE PRESIDENTS.
>> EVERYBODY COME TOGETHER.
STOP YOUR GREED, STOP THE DRUGS,
STOP YOUR SEXY INTERNET
PORNOGRAPHY.
WHEN WILL IT STOP?
WE WILL NEVER KNOW.
YEAH, COMO.
CHECK.
♪ SO MUCH PAIN IN THE USA
SO MUCH PAIN IN THE WORLD
TODAY I SAID WHY I SAID WHY
I SAID WHY ♪
♪ WHY ARE WE FIGHTING FOR ♪
>> IT'S BEGINNING TO LOOK LIKE I
HAVE A SERIOUS PORNOGRAPHY
ADDICTION.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CELL PHONE, LAPTOP, FAMILY
DESKTOP, ALL MY DEVICES,
SWAMPED.
♪ WHO ♪
I JUST NEED A BREAK.
BIG SHOUTS TO PUFFY, DMX, NO
GLOBAL WARMING.
BUT FIRST, STOP THE PORNO.
>> YES.
>> FREE MY MIND, I NEED TO
SLEEP.
LET ME REST.
♪ SO MUCH PAIN IN THE USA
SO MUCH PAIN IN THE WORLD
TODAY I SAID WHY I SAID WHY
I SAID WHY ♪
>> PORNO.
NOW CORY'S THE MAN.
♪ WHY ARE WE FIGHTING FOR ♪
>> I KNOW THAT I HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH PORNOGRAPHY.
♪ SO MUCH PAIN IN THE USA
SO MUCH PAIN IN THE WORLD
TODAY I SAID WHY I SAID WHY
I SAID WHY ♪
♪ WHY ARE WE FIGHTING FOR ♪
♪♪♪
>> I CANNOT STOP WATCHING.
I LOVE EVERYBODIES TYPES OF
BODIES.
I CAN'T GET ENOUGH.
♪ I SAY WHY ARE WE FIGHTING
FOR ♪
>> I PRAY FOR PEACE, I LOVE THE
WORLD.
RESPECT.
♪♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]